all right I'm here at the kawaru bridge
in New Zealand where the first person
threw themselves off this bridge with
nothing but an elastic band tied around
their like so I'm going to give it a
shot today and find out what it feels to
accelerate down at the acceleration due
to gravity 9.8 meters of second squared
now you can tell that I'm nervous by
that cheesy grin in the idiotic wave a
long way down there
the worst part of bungee jumping is the
half hour wait before you actually jump
you have to watch other people and well
they don't always make it look so
enjoyable so this is a true story
actually when I was about 7 I climbed
out to the top of the high diving board
and the local baby pool and then I got
so scared by looking down that I back
down back down the stairs rather than
jump off a diving board so this is my
day for redemption
are you accelerated
now II kind of know but they'll be over
before you know it
doridori about hacking so the moment of
truth would I put on a brave face no it
is that cheesy yeah and there's the wave
it's the wave again or just get off the
platform you can hear me can't down here
yep there's the wave again
that was freaking awesome just the
experience when you leap off and you
realize you're falling and see that
water rushing up towards you is
absolutely incredible it's over before
you know it just not as scary as you
would think Anna I couldn't figure out
what the acceleration was as it was
going down but you know it felt hi
fellows
very great increase in your rate of
speed so Oh
oh my god knows fast huh
loved it
[Music]
now as silly as I may have looked at
least I wasn't as bad as this guy a note
to first timers jumping feet first may
seem less scary but it's actually a bad
idea